hi I'm Rhea and this is my recipe for
giant soup dumpling so I made this giant
mochi ice cream video and seems like
audience really enjoyed it then I was
wondering what else I can make Jaya and
its subducting this time a few years ago
when I made this video giant soup
dumpling was really popular at
restaurants and I was wondering if I
could show people a way to make a home
using gelatin is an easy way of making
soup dumpling at home because gelatin
melts with heat so when you finish
steaming it it basically becomes soup so
I had to test this three or four times
because when I was testing the feeling
wasn't fully cooked so I was wondering
what was wrong and I found out induction
stopped top it's not strong enough to
create strong steam to steam up the huge
soot dumpling and also I was using
bamboo steamer and bamboo basket was not
filled enough so steam was escaping so I
decided to use aluminum foil to wrap
around that and it worked perfectly this
is really delicious tasty Japan actually
did a video where they tried to
replicate and they were really impressed
with how tasty was it's all in Japanese
so it's difficult to understand but they
things like really enjoy that there's my
favorite soup dumpling restaurant but
there is always a long line and also
giant soup dumpling place it's located
in New York and outside of LA I believe
so I wanted to make a home could that's
something I always do
if the restaurants too far away or there
it's a long one you have to weigh more
than one hour I just wanted to make a
home because I like making a home and I
don't need to leave my house
I'm really proud of this recipe and I
think you guys should try making it a
home
it may seem intimidating to try and make
a dish like this but I think you can do
it when it's cold it's solid so it's
easy to wrap it so when you're making
dumpling dough make sure H is thinner
than that Center because you don't want
to go together at the top and twist it
so the top ends up becoming very tough
and thick so in order to see if it's
really cooked or not you can poke a
small hole with a toothpick or something
if clear juice is coming out then it's
fully cooked if it's pinkish or pink
then it's undercooked and you need to
cook more time at the end of the video I
used straw to drink the soup because all
the restaurant was doing so but you
don't need to do it because soup is
really hard and I don't want you to bind
yourself so I made a giant mochi video
and I made a giant soup dumpling what
other food you want me to make giant
comment below I will make giant as
always thank you for watching if you
make suggestion why else can I say
thank you for watching okay thank you
for watching and I will see you next
time